Good afternoon, Sley's family,
members of the community.
My name is Navarro.  I am the
very proud administrator of this
school.
I want to thank everyone
here
for taking the time today to
help the community.
If you've had a chance to give your
opinion or ask a question, I'm very
grateful to Matías Segura, our
amazing super-tenant, and his
leadership team for making time in
today's agenda to give us this
opportunity.  I'm going to transition now
to Cristina Gen,
who will repeat the rules for
today's meeting.
Hello, hello.  Hello everyone.  Thank you for
being here today.  I'm going to
start with some rules.
If you need to go to the bathroom, I imagine
you know because it's your school, but
if not, here, uh, go out the door and
take a right.  So, let's take a
look at today's agenda, and
also, uh, those are the rules of the
meeting, and from there we'll start
with a summary of what we're going to
discuss today, and also, uh,
information from the
comment cards, and we're going to repeat the information from
the comment cards to have a
discussion.
I imagine Matías will also
thank the community.
You have also communicated and have
been a very open group for
communication, and we are going to have a
very good conversation
today.  So, these are the rules of
the meeting guidelines.  I'm
not going to read them all right now, but the goal is
that we are creating a future,
a future together.  These
are difficult spaces to
find ourselves in today.  So,
I want to work together, to
honor the time we have.   We
also want to create
one-minute comments.  We have about an hour and a half
to be here.  So, let's think, we
can give the opportunity to the
maximum number of people, to everyone, to
honor everyone.
Honor the process,
the impact, our space and
voice, and create solutions,
create open topics, and give empathy
to others.  If we approach things with
empathy, we'll do better.
Uh, also with the meeting and the
purpose, we are here to answer
questions and also talk about
future solutions.  At this time we are going to
talk about the questions that were
submitted with the
question cards.  Our group has already
looked at several things, so several
people were asking
very similar questions and we grouped them together.  Also,
understand the
reasoning and the comprehension
to be
able to deliver the information
next week and also the
financial proposal that is coming next month.  And
from here we're going to hand him over to the
superintendent right now.
Well, first of all I want to
thank everyone for being here this
afternoon
and also acknowledge the
difficulty of this conversation.
I am a person who strongly loves
our schools.  You may not
know, I'm from the south of Austen.  I
was there, I lived there, I was a
family man in Sunset Valley.  My first
reference to parents was here in Sunset
Valley.  I have walked the halls
of this school.  This is very difficult
for many individuals and for the
staff as well.  I'm hopeful that
we can have this conversation and
talk about everything and
ask everyone for permission to move
forward.  What we want to do
today is develop a
school system, to reach a point where
our resources, which are precious
, we can deliver them to
the students and
school communities that need them, those who
need them most.  and at the same time create
academic experiences across
all students, across
the entire Austin department, and we can
look at all the neighborhoods and we can
define the neighborhoods.  I want to clarify,
we have amazing schools
everywhere, but not all students
are receiving the resources and support they
need.  That is not the fault of this
administration or this board of directors.
This comes from levels 144
of decisions they made to get to
this point.  So, when we're
talking about what it means right now
and the plan, uh, that we want to give
voice to several points, it's not a
perfect plan.  There never is, there never is.  But we do
want to align
referral patterns.  There are parts of OCEN, you
know, to the west they know they have
lines.  Uh, you know that all the uh
high schools that go to
high school in Merken, in Anderson, in
Gorisky, in Buy e but where you don't
see them, you don't see them east of Austin.
We have middle schools that go to four or
five high schools, they split up,
the PTA group can't be maintained, and
as a school system we've never
seen it this way.  So, this
plan clarifies it.
There is also a financial difficulty,
it is being felt at the moment, they already know about the
budget and we are going to have
conversations.  Hey, Matias, what
did you do 2 years ago, 5 years ago?
I want to let you know that the board of
directors, I too, have been
quite intentional in paying for
things that align with our values ​​and
stopping things that we could to
protect our schools.  We did it
during the past two years, but there
are many responses at the federal level,
the pressure we have at the state level,
that we cannot continue without another, says
the real risk, well, financial, a
financial risk.  I want to be very
clear, one of the things that a
Texas education is not is not
accounting, it is
financial literacy,
solvency.
This plan aims to reduce the number of
open spaces in each school.  They are areas of
boundaries and also of consolidation.   It's
also about trying to take the weight off
any part of OSIN.
In the last 20 years there was an argument
that was made that in the eastern areas of
Austin they took all the weight in
terms of school improvement.
So, since we're talking about
movement, then a complete,
comprehensive language, so that these plans will be of
great help from here to the future, so that
all emerging
bilingual students can have it and
try to create so that they can
overcome and not put that burden on just one
part of the city in terms of
consolidation.  On the other hand, we are
in a very big difficulty
in terms of accounting.  You
know that our responsibility plan
came out in 4 or 5 years and it did make it
quite difficult for us and we were able to move the
system three or four years back, I think
we could reach 70% and maintain
teachers.  We now have 88%.
Uh, I was able to hire 34 female
directors a while ago, now I'm looking at more than
60, but if I can't talk about these
transformation plans—and we'll
talk about that a little later—
we're at risk of not being
able to maintain control.  And I tell you this
because it is very important to me
as the leader of this organization that
our board of directors, the people
you elected, have the ability to
determine how to educate our
students, the 70,000 students that
are throughout the Austri district.  If
you are at very high risk
throughout the city.  I am not willing to downplay its
importance.  I am
ready to face it, but this
plan is also taking that into account.
Lately, finally, I want to talk
about the difficulty of the rules
of transfer.  They're ugly right now
, there are some that it's time
to retire because they didn't really make
sense.  They were made years
ago.  Then they were going from East
Austin, other parts of Austin, and
transfer rules and procedures that
some have
too high a registration and that should never have been the
case.  So this plan is also
taking that point into account at the moment.
So we're going to
face that too.  There are multiple levels and steps
.  So, no, if we are
looking at it in isolation it
would be different, but we cannot
look at it that way.  So, I'm going to
continue with this slide
to give you more detail about
this.  But in terms of Sunset Valley,
this elementary school,
this has the
school movement, full dual language
comprehensive.
In the 45, in the postal code, I am
very familiar with this
trying to move access from where you
live right now in terms of
locations to a place where there is a
higher population.  We know where it is
located, and we also know that
historically it has been quite difficult for
those families to have access to the
necessary schools.  So, where
we want to create the comprehensive dual language
is where there are emerging
bilingual students.  Uh, we're moving them in
a reverse way and the numbers
are quite low at the moment.  We need to
assign these students
to Sunset Valley.
So, we're going to reassign him to Boun or
Conningham.  These are two
amazing schools in terms of
neighborhood schools, and we're not just looking at one
school or another, either Joseln's or
Boon's or Paul's.  We're looking at
the entire region and understanding
how one movement
impacts another, the logic behind it, and how to
get to that point. Obviously, it's not
perfect and needs adjusting, but
I want to let you know our
thoughts on how we got to
this point and the
factors we're considering
to move forward with this plan.
Okay, thank you very much, Mr. Segura.
I am the operations officer for
Austin IST.  Um, I imagine I'll
take you through these slides
so you're ready, and I know we have
plenty of time to do
answers, questions, and answers.  I'll
try to get through it quickly.  As you
know, the question is, what does
this mean for my school?  The
building would be closed and the
students reassigned
to Conningham Primary Schools.  and
boom.  And in the boundary zones, we're going
to talk about that a little more
specifically, a little further back.  He
just talked about the program and how we
would be moving this program forward.  It would be
a little different with Austen ISD.
We'll talk about that in more detail in the
future.  So, in
terms of the technical school and
Ogan's program.  Uh, school.
If you live within the current Sunset
Valley boundary,
as I said before, you can
choose to go to the assigned school or you
can also enroll in a
priority place in the
dual language program.
If you are a student who has been
transferred, you can return to your
assigned school or request
priority placement in the Language program.  And we
also have
space at Odam Primary School
to support everyone, and here too.
So now we're going to talk about the
boundary change, the
assist zones, and this is something that was in the
proposal in this package. Here on the
left are the boundary zones
of Sunset Valley, and on the right are
the lines that would be changed.
So, you would be, uh, you would be ringing in
this area to Cunningham and what's in
pink, uh, you would be reassigned to Boom.
So, certain things that are here.
Now let's get down to business.  Okay,
we're going to ask Cristina, let's
start with the questions and answers
and what we've heard at a high level from
all of you.  It's been incredible, the
feedback and the organization they've
had here at this school.  I appreciate your
comments and the level at which
you shared all the information.
Okay, before we begin, I want to introduce
the board members. We have our
secretary, Andrew Gonzalez, and also
board member number 7, Dr. Kofman.
Thank you.
Let's start with the
questions section on the cards.
All students at School S
will also be able to participate in
Wal's language program and the new
schools.
Thank you, thank you for being here
and it makes me happy to see so many
familiar family members.  My name is Beca.
I have the honor of supporting parents
in dual language programs.
It is important
to know that we have enough
seats available at ODOM to ensure
that all students
transferring to the
elementary school and all students
participating in the program here in
Sunset Valley have enough
seats
for the other schools.
The other question
is, which schools do they
belong to?  We are committed
to prioritizing students coming
from school 11, okay?  so that they have
a place, only ensuring
we have made a commitment
to reduce any disruption where we can
and also acknowledge with the
committee of commissioners.
That is our goal.
We know that this plan includes
moving and the goal would be to ensure that
everyone who chose to
stay together has a place
reserved in Odom.  But these are also
basic comments that apply to
other programs that we have in full.
That's the case.
If the people who are here
currently going to 11 are automatically approved
and given priority.
Yes, if you understand me.  We just want to
know if we can prove the place you
have here at the school for the
Set school.   It
must be true, because they would have,
for example,
in the guaranteed transfer
for the
But that would include all the
transfers that are considered and
just making sure that one of
the languages ​​here is a little
softer than what we will need
and it would only be to have a little
control, but the language
transfer would be different things, which
is what is in the original plan.  I
can tell you verbally that we are
getting very close to the goal, but I ca
n't tell you that it's in the plan,
but well, I can already tell you that we
are very close to that goal as
well.
Well, most of our
emerging Dual program families coming to this
school will have the same patterns
for student transportation and will
have the same opportunities with the entire
community.
Some families may live more
than 2 miles away.   Are
there any priorities for this
school to ensure they have
and maintain the
transportation program?  It's not an original program, we don't
have that included, but thanks to
Superintendent Segura
we have already clarified that this is very
important and we have made the
considerations not only for
the school, they are valid for other schools
as well.
And we can continue with that, no matter
the cost, because it's something we're
still working on
and it's important, super important
for families.
Just to be very precise about this,
for the four elementary schools that
will receive these programs, which are
Sánchez and Bun, we want to make sure that
we are very close to all the schools that we are
going to incorporate so that they have
safe transportation in
that area
so that the students have access.
Being close to the school
helps them, but transportation could be a factor.
We can take advantage of
transportation at any time, but throughout the
district we can look for
solutions, and
transportation will be provided.  It's something that's already been
considered and we're taking it into account, and I
think we're going to get to that point.
This question concerns the
dual emerging language students who may be
included within the boundaries that
Sunset Valley School may include.  And in
that case, I ca
n't say for sure that we're going to
provide this transportation service,
but it's
something that we don't currently have within our
policies. However, I can
recognize the challenges it may bring us,
but specifically regarding that element of that
question,
we could provide transportation
within that consensus,
but obviously there is a cost associated
with this.  We will have to see
where the students reside, whether it is a program of the
enjual or if it is closer for that
student or if it would have to be part of
another special program
so that they have access in another way
as if they had it in ODOM.  That's already
on the table and it's part of the
process we
're including
because the ODM school is going to be non-
sonic.  All students who
graduate from the dual English language program
will help the district.
A very good question that has been
coming up lately,
and of course, we are reading all the little
cards on the
comment cards that are given to us, but
we are looking at Peters, the
superintendent has already spoken about Peters,
specifically
for the schools that are not
zoned and those that are
already established.  That would be something we are
currently
mapping, including them on the
maps,
but I'm just going to share with you
that we are also including
schools that are naturally
delineated that we are going to include, but we are
also part of the
conversations we are having and it is
very important to continue with the
programs so you know that it is something
we are considering as we are
having more conversations.
Now I am very worried about my other
daughter, who receives special education
for speech therapy.  And thanks to the
teacher and the therapists who have
helped us with this whole process.  My daughter has
received help.  I just want to
make sure that this type of population
will not be affected.
I want to include a little bit in that question,
in the special education program that we are
trying to stabilize the
system.  I want to point out that
these staff placements are something
we need, well, not
certified workers
or certified teachers,
these are incorporated, but they are not
in the strategic program of the program.
There are obviously questions about what
's included in the plan, the
positions for special education are
included, but
the staff, the
team we're hiring is
included in the plan of what's
needed.  The staff obviously
need the special training to
be licensed and have the
specialty, but
the district is also handling all
the other special programs and it's
something I just want to clarify
.  Thank you for being here this
afternoon.
To this question, all
speech therapies, occupational therapies,
dyslexia, dyslexia interventions,
behavioral supports, all these
services could even include
nursing, will go with their own
student.
These are within the
education program and will guide them with all the
educational support that the
students need.  for students
receiving special education at this
established school.
We're going to have our meetings,
the AR meetings, which are the meetings
that determine what
special services will be held during
the spring, and those services will
follow the child to the schools they are
assigned to in a new school.  for
updating programs that
include dual language programs
and emerging programs.  We are going to
test these, we are going to make sure that
these services are provided, which
include, for example, special education
for early childhood and all
special education programs will
be included.  All
services will be included and will
continue with students through
middle and high school, but My
Skills and
early childhood skills programs will be
determined by circumstances and will be
considered according to where
students are placed in the new
schools they go to.  But
speech therapy,
occupational therapy,
behavioral interventions, all
those services will be prohibited from being
provided in all
Austin district schools.
What is the plan for the transition of
teachers in the new programs, in the
new schools?  I think that's good.   We
are carefully reviewing all
staff locations.
There is no set plan to reduce the
number of positions or jobs, such as
teachers,
teaching assistants, or
speech therapists.  We need to
see where these
specialists are going to be of service.  We have
many providers, such as
speech therapists or
diagnostic specialists, who will be
serving. In fact, they already work in
different schools, and we will be
closely monitoring which schools in this
community they will continue to serve
and what type of
specialist therapists are available.
But we don't have a
specific health provider plan in place for
this plan.  I don't understand
why
Jaslin is being kept in one
place, an open campus instead of
Sunset,
because all the paths are
fenced off.
So,
sorry, I didn't hear the
question.
I always emphasize when we talk about
another school and what the campus of another
school is.  But this, as I said before,
this is an original approach in
which all schools and all
students are told what goals
are included in the plan.  I want to
identify,
we have many schools that use
the transportation system, it is in
high demand and we have a stabilized program
so that they can be in the
complete education and program they need.
But when it comes to Dawson,
we can narrow down what the movement of
other schools is, which school
is closest, for example, Seon.
Well, stay at Joselin school.
There are many schools where everything happens in
a small area.  We can talk about the
facilities, the access, we've already created the
rubric of what our alignments will be
and try to
find an approach.  Another thing I can
say is,
we can identify the schools and the
programs in those schools,
because we feel like Joseln,
the program has supported and there has been a
change, I'm not going to deny it, there has been
a change from what is
currently happening.   It's going to
be a sonified school,
but
because of that,
the students have transferred to
schools that are a little further
north, but if we had thought about what it would
look like in the transfer team,
we are slowly creating access to
those programs within Austin.
What I'm going to say is that it wasn't
one of the moves we
were trying to make to get closer to
the goal, to be able to point out all these
points simultaneously, and we're
talking about the different details of
why it's this street or it would be another street, which
would be a conversation
within a general approach of
how we would do it.
I think people want it
one way and not another, but we
can reduce it all to a rubric.
When the rubric came out, we originally
started,
we had conversations with the
consolidation plans,
we identified that we have limits in the
system and we have the
original limits.  Each school impacts
another school.  It is the solution and the
plans in the draft that we have already
outlined for everything we have
mentioned in the other meetings
previously.
In the next question, when will
these proposed changes begin?
How many students do you expect to be in
each of these
new classrooms?
There is a legal maximum for a
classroom.
Let's talk
briefly about classrooms.  This is
proposed in August
2026, which is at the beginning of the
next school year.  We have a short amount of time
to do this
and we've been working on this for 2
years, so more importantly, we need to
make sure that the timing, the timeline
, the chronology, we make
the right choices.  and that the
decisions are viable, that they can be
made.  That would be in August 2026. And the
other two questions included here,
how many students do you expect to be in the
classroom?
The number of students is not changing
so far.  I just
want to mention that, but to the fullest extent
legally possible.  Okay, what's the range?  It's not what
we typically see in the
Austin school district,
but we do have, for example,
compact classrooms; we can have 18, 20,
23 in each classroom according to what is
allowed.
In terms of leadership at each school,
that number can be exceeded if it depends on
the agency providing it, but we are
trying not to follow this same path;
we are trying to address this,
but it is not part of the plan and we
are not considering it.  The last thing
I would say is that
according to the 2026 school year plan
, I want to mention this because there have
been many conversations
about how much time is needed and it feels like we are
rushing things a bit and that a lot is
happening in a short amount of time, but
I want to put this into perspective.  For example,
we started the community plans in
February and March and we will continue
taking votes in November and we already have the
plan, the right one.  I want you to know
what is very important to
us,
for me it is to make sure that we don't
do more things than people
really need, the family needs.   We
need to have a plan in place so we have time to
plan it, and we have this system.
We're not only preparing for the
2026-2027 school year, but
especially since the year starts with
plans beginning in November and continuing
until March, and the election takes place in
December. We've already lost one
of the four months we have, and
frustration with the
registration system can escalate. If we don't
have the time to implement
how we can
introduce more problems than someone else will have to deal with, so
the next school will have to deal
with it.  So, it's very important for
me to be honest about what we're going to lose
if we delay the votes and the action.
What I'm going to say is that I will
never, ever, ever propose or
commit to making a change in the
next semester.  We've done it
before, woman hasn't noted it, but a
few years ago and we had some pretty
significant changes in Vendes, in
Marles and we changed the high school, the
international high school
and we had problems uh during the summer
and we had good to be able to have a
successful launch with the program.   This is
something that is currently under review
for us in this timeline, and
whether it is appropriate.
If we miss the timeline chronology
,
let's have the opportunity to
introduce it at a future time.  But I
just want to be honest about that,
as we're discussing, talking
about the timeline and the
chronology so you know that we have
time for the process and for
our team as well, so that
we're within this chronology, so
that we have the whole plan ready
by December because you're the ones who
want to know, so that we can move
forward, that we have everything
planned well.  Something that can happen
when it depends on the votes and how
they lean, because the reason for this
is
because I, for example, do not have the
authority to know what the
qualification is to change the limits
that are delimited.  That's why the
sequence of the plan is coordinated
and we possibly have the vote
in December, then in January
we could have changes in personnel,
but we also work with other
communities to be in agreement.   I just
want you to know that there are
many things happening behind the
scenes that we don't know about at that
level, and it affects us, and well, we can
be with all the families.   I would
also like them to know.   I would
also like to know if the value of
the land, the potential profit from
selling or remodeling, would play a role
in that decision.  If that's the case, the community
deserves to understand it, right?
In this process, the value
of the land did not
play a significant role.
When we think, we have
been clear that we want to
move forward in this process and plan
with the community
and to do what makes the most sense
with the community.
And now, as PIS prepared, Pis, uh,
they're integrated, right?  Because
the students are still thinking, and
we can also have a childcare center there
.
And now the important thing is that the district
supports the teachers too.
We are also looking for other solutions.   He
wasn't part of it, he was never a
major factor.
We recognize
that this process
is a potential that we can estimate,
but it is only part of the process.
But we will never truly separate
the decision from what the
community needs.
What I don't understand is the resonation
of those of us who live south of William
Hano and west of Westgate to send
our children to Sabon instead of
Akawan.  Living west of West Gate
means that the fastest route to
Bunnie Elementary likely took
many families south of Davis,
about 500 feet from the elementary
epoch before continuing west toward
Brody and beyond.  And half a mile for
Bonnie improved her within the district that she's
considering changing the
Bona Elementary boundary, right?  A school in
their neighborhood with their neighbors.   Please excuse
me if I forgot to make the
introductions.
I am Rachel FR, I am the planner
for the consolidation board.
This is what we are seeing.  This is
an exact example of what can
help us work now.
We're checking every day
and we don't stop, but we're looking for every
detail to make sure
that if it's a small change, that only
affects a few blocks, it's easy,
right?  And a change is going to happen, but only if it does
n't align with another high school,
or if the high school, which is the school on the
other side, is too full or too empty.
All of that plays a role in these
changes.
So, that's why the details we're
talking about are important, because
that can be reflected in the changes
and the version of what we're discussing.   I
urge you to please
review those boundaries with the district because our
area has been uniquely shaped and mapped out,
and it aligns with
our daily connections.
We are also the only neighborhood
north of Highway 290 that is not assigned to
Austin High School.  In addition, Barton
view appears to be the only
small neighborhood that has been reassigned and is completely
new, while most
other areas are in transition along
with another new school.  We're also
looking at this school, this area,
and we're going to review it this week.
So, I don't have anything definitive
yet, but we want to review your
feedback as well
and we're not going to make the changes.  We're going to
tell you why.
I'm curious to know
if the district is open to
working with a
two-way dual language program, a whole-
school bidirectional program that uses SB 1882,
sharing part of the curriculum
, professional development, staffing
, family involvement, and
also the same principal, supervisor,
someone who ideally only works with
these four schools.  A partnership would
also bring in additional funding, which
could offset some of the
program's costs and allow for that
narrow administrative range.   We
started working on this a few years ago
, partnering with
different types of schools, whether it was a
charter school, I do
n't remember the
names right now, right?  Sorry.
So there are some charters that could
be linked to an
improvement model.  Right now there's one in
Méndez
and the way this has evolved,
the access, the way
they have their funds, that has been changing and
that has something to do with it.  I'm not
entirely convinced that there's much opportunity
for financing.
This is hard to see.
We reviewed this.  Let's see if
a partner comes along.  Let's see what happens.
Then we'll draw up a contract and that's how it would
happen.
One of the things we looked at to
ensure
everyone had the same leadership style was
the way they described it.   I had
the pleasure of hiring
her.  He does an excellent job.
So we need to connect with the
other programs as well, and I want to
strengthen them and improve how we support
these programs as we move
to do more places
and also add a supervisor,
an executive director for schools,
schools that historically
have had the same resources as
others.
schools that have not performed
well.  Uh, some challenges, some of us
also know
that we have 11 to 12 per teacher.
So, we want to see how we can
have this, uh, how many students per
teacher,
but the most important thing for
education to work well
is that these details are taken into account
.
The association that is made
is not so simple either, is it?
There's a lot we need to review, like
these questions, but I understand
the anxiety that may arise in this
regard.   I
would also like to invite you to explain a
little more about this.  I am excited
about the curriculum and the
special learning opportunities.  Ah, there's going to be
a small change.
We will use high-quality materials
and also partner with
multilingual education.
Also, align the curricula
that are checking literacy
and also the
dual language students.  It's a great partnership
that I want to have.  Uh, when we spoke
with the superintendent of schools
many years ago.
It was about professional learning
in the study plan.  I also want to mention
that it
simply requires professional training.
We incorporate a lot of this
professional learning aspect, and in the
school setting we have
professional learning communities to
discuss lessons,
and there is a lot of collaboration when we talk
about teaching situations.
Thank you for being here this afternoon.
I want to add that we are very
focused on professional training
also for executive directors
who support high schools so that they
follow dual language models, not
only in schools where the
program is implemented throughout the school.
All the supervising directors
are very familiar with the program
and we have very strong support for
the directors and that's why we
will also be on the same page with the supervisor of directors for this
partnership.
Two more comments.
How much
taxpayer money was spent on renovations at
Sans Bade school?  And we want him to
announce that this school is scheduled and
now he tells us they're going to close it,
right?  Parents should have
confidence in the district when
such poor planning results in
wasted
taxpayer dollars.  So, how does
this happen?  TRUE?
They should know.  That comes with all
schools.
This is truly amazing, and every school
has a project, whether it's modernization
or simply updating, improving, or
renovating them. But specifically,
the issue of security is also
very important, such as improving
the cameras. We will always be
looking for ways to improve
schools.  We started
consolidations when we had the bonus.
No, definitely not.
But really no school district
wants to be in this situation we're in
right now,
but we still have the
compliance piece,
a security center,
and also with the Texas Education Agency,
which recently
assured us that we have the
school security features,
and that's why we're committed as a
school,
as a school district, to
meeting this
compliance requirement.
I also want to add just to
clarify that if there is a student
in the schools, we want to do our
best to ensure that it is working, that it
is safe, and that it requires any
improvements.
In 2021 we had the bond program; we did
n't know we were going to have this
problem in 2025. Now we find out
that we
have to invest in this form
of SB.
Now we're facing
a shortage of educators in
schools
and we need to recover, right?
We knew we were going to be here,
right?
I was in charge of the operation at
that time.  I never thought that at that
moment we were going to reach that point,
because of the pressure on our state,
that we were going to have a moment to
breathe.
What happened at the federal level, that
interruption and Title II, Title III, and
Title IV, is hitting us
hard. The
$1,000 loss has significantly
impacted special education, supporting
many people in Austin
who have supported all our
educators, and so overnight I had to
support them because I didn't know, we didn't
anticipate it.
We have invested many dollars
very carefully.
We want to and can build very
quickly in a way that many
cannot.  Hopefully they saw it in
202122.
Our ability, our ability to
build compared to other
disciplines, they are seeing us because we
do it very well, knowing, well,
realizing that we didn't know what
was coming, we wouldn't have been able to
make those decisions, but we weren't
ready for that decision.  And to add
to this, we also have a
community bond that is managed by a
committee.  They also give us
feedback on all projects in
financial terms.   It's
also important that we have a
community-wide committee to gather
input from everyone who's voting
and to help us allocate the
remaining dollars. That's
our goal.
Finally, this is the last question
in the card comments.  I am
deeply dismayed that it
appears that PKIEN students have been taken into account
in Plan A, but as
we review the
proposed plan, we see that only
kindergarten and above students
would be guaranteed a place in ORAM.
Um, I suggest that the OSTE include
PRKinder students in the
consolidation plan to ensure that the
dual language model in all
schools remains truly
comprehensive, and that families who have
implemented this program continue to do so
.  Thank you so much for the
comment card.  If we're looking at
pre-kindergarten and the way they're going to
continue, and yes, maybe there will be a change
in this in this next draft.   I
also want to say, this
pre-index student was included in the plan,
but progress towards the plan based
on the plan will be clarified in
the transfer rules.  So,
I want to be very clear about all the
scenarios you might encounter. We're going
to have a very clear and detailed
answer on how to make the move and
how we can ensure that the
disruption for your family is as
minimal as possible.  The plan we were
always going to consider was for the
pre-infant, it was going to be a comprehensive dual language
, it was going to be an answer, it hasn't
been, we haven't
said it clearly, we're going to do it from now on
.  Okay, that's it for
the comment cards, but before we
start asking any questions you may have,
I want to draw your attention to what's
coming up.  This is the first day
that Mr. Segura is visiting this school;
you are the second.
We were in Martin this morning.  We're also going
to have a workshop on
Monday, a virtual meeting
focused on East Austin on
Tuesday, and another workshop on Thursday, and
the board vote is on Thursday.  There are
many things to come and
next Friday will be the
updated plan, the new draft.
And next week, on November 6,
they will have the opportunity to debate and
discuss that plan.  And November 20th
is the final date
to cast your votes.
Okay, if you'd like, if
anyone has a question, and
yes, I also want to let you know, we
're recording this to share with the
community, and for those who also
need Spanish, we'll be
helping with the microphone for everyone
else right now.  Who's going to
start?  Okay, I can start here.
Okay, very good.
Okay, with this we're going to start and
go from one side to the other.  Okay.  Hi,
you mentioned the
enrollment timeline.  I knew that it was going to
take a little longer to find out what
the complete and personal plan was going to be at
this time.  They're not
going to do that in November.
Well,
the transfer process starts in November.  I want
to clarify, we want to be very intentional
with the students.   They
are creating
an experience that is not typical.
So, when we're going to deliver the
plan, we're going to be responding to the
enrollment process,
because the system,
we want to ensure that when you're
entering the system, let's say, if you're
in Sunset Valley, you'd be going to the
school where you're already enrolled, or
50%
of those who have the opportunity to go to
OREM would be part of ensuring that the
system can integrate this, and those
adjustments will be integrated
in terms of staff before
enrollment.  It depends on when they're going to
register; we want to protect, so we're
going to give you options.  And you tell me,
"Matías, based on the plan, I think I'd like to
go now, and chronologically
, we're going to get to this
point, and for some reason in the future,
say, 'You know what? I don't want to go all the way
there anymore.' We want to support you in making
that adjustment because we know it's a
change from what you were expecting.
Yes, there are certain things we need to
organize a little more. The staff does
n't usually make the
full adjustment until spring. That's why it's
important to start with the principal in
December because that's where it begins, and we do
n't stop until almost the end of February
or March, but there's time. There should be
options.
Thank you. Uh,
there are certain notes. The comment, I
was more worried. Oh, but it's not
here anymore. I have two students who
are here, and I understand that maybe they won't
continue at this school, but
I feel that Son Valley is
an incredible place for a
neighborhood school. The rubric they used at
that time was the best of
all the elementary schools in this
area, and it's the only one that was going to lose."  I was
told it was very empty.
Unfortunately, the situation we
're in is one school against the
other. Sunset Valley is
in a
pretty bad area, in a pretty bad place.
We could go to Sunrise right now, and they're
doing some really good things and maybe they'll
move forward, but everyone who doesn't have a
place is
defecating, using the bathroom
wherever they can.
There are mental health issues happening right now. Next door there's a
gas station that
sells liquor and marijuana. It's like something out of a
news report. It's a
news report's dream to give; it looks like a jail. There's nowhere to
park.
I'm a student council member from
Sunset Valley. We have
police parking, we have places to pick up and
drop off students.
Once a year, or once a week,
we can go and talk. We have a
spectacular, beautiful campus. I'm a
student council member. We give $1,000 to the
PIA, and we want to support the
school. We wanted to hear from you on the call
earlier, I think it was
last week. Oro, the parents from Oro didn't
even want us to...  This program was
moved to this location. So, I do
n't understand why they're going to remove this
school from this community when we're
doing so well, we're also getting there
with our votes, with our
money. I don't know, I can't
answer. Yes. Okay. I didn't know if
you wanted me to answer.
So, what I would say is that
there are so many schools that are feeling
the impact right now. I want
to clarify, there are many people who
honestly love or support, to be
honest.
So, I want to clarify,
we recognize that Soner Valley
supports the school itself, and we want to
support all the schools in
Austin right now, and it's not happening right now
. I'm at a point,
I don't have the ability to give resources
to all the schools;
there are 116 schools at this
point.
So, wherever there's a
specific school, everyone is going to have
difficulties right now. If there are
students in the
boundary zone changes that are all along the
border, and honestly, that's the
truth. So, they're in the
emerging bilingual 24%, quite difficult, and it's
moving in that direction.  Reverse.
So, in logistical terms,
we have to have the right access.
So, it was never one thing or the other
that gave focus to this plan. It was
more that these are families who love to be here now,
but they can't get there because
they're working multiple jobs at the same
time. They don't have the resources, they don't
have the access. But you don't think
this happens here too. But I
'm telling you that everyone has a
different experience,
and I don't want to...
I feel that at this moment, this plan, we've
reached this point, this draft
is a plan, it's a draft with the
process we've created over
many months, with the
long-term effort of the bond, the bond plan.
So, in terms of... it didn't start from
scratch and we're here now. We're going to
listen to more feedback and we're going to make
adjustments, but I don't want you to think that I don't
understand or that I don't value the
immense support you've had in this
community.
This is what frustrates me the most, and that's why it hurts me that
you matter, but I also hate
that we're in this position as a
district.
Thank you for being here.  Here. Um, my
questions are a combination of these
two, but as a community,
why not give us this assurance
that there's stability, that they're going to
say, "Let's offer it to you to
ensure we can make the
right decision?" I love it. No, we love
our district and we support you.
Nobody wants you to come in and take away our
right. If you couldn't assure us,
parents, we need the support,
here it comes. If you choose it, obviously
if you want to come, well, no problem,
but why not? Okay. I want the
parents, the families, to understand that this
is a good question. If I could tell you right now, to
the extent
possible, to have that support and this
commitment from me,
being your principal, and I've been able to
meet with all the principals going through
this change right now. What
you want is what I want,
too. Right now, we don't have the
vote, and we're still getting
feedback from all over the community, and
maybe it could change. One thing I don't
want to do is interrupt,
interrupt
things in the middle of this  The moment
when it comes to the transformation plans
is ready to begin. What do
you need from me? And
unfortunately, I can't
say yes yet because we're not
concrete. If we don't reach that point,
everyone, many people, are going to be very
disappointed. So, at this moment, what
you want and what I want
the community to want in general is what I
think we could get to
. At this moment, we haven't
specifically arrived because we're missing the board vote
and the
specific plan, but it's something that can
establish that stability and create it in
Zavala or elsewhere, but we haven't
reached that point yet. But that's
precisely why we
prefer to see something that can make that
decision itself. I value our
staff, and I want her to stay
here with us. I have no doubt that's
true. So, I want you to
know that we're going to be ready. I can't
commit at that point yet
because we haven't reached that point in the
process. Thank you for being here, and
thank you to the Sid community for being
so respectful and
kind in the comments.
When we're talking  From the majority of
high-income students, how will this
impact Title I funding, like
ontology,
etc., that the community can receive
and needs?
So, for Title I dollars right now, they're
distributed based on the
total number of students who are
economically disadvantaged. So,
something I can tell you is that a
few years ago, over 60%
were economically disadvantaged, but
with the changes across the city, we
were 65, 55, 50, 45. We're trying
to stay above 50%. The changes to
immigration laws are affecting us
quite a bit right now. We're
below that right now because there are
immigrant families who have come here
who need to come, and there are those who have been
told they have to leave.
So, many of the families that
would be in this group of
economically disadvantaged students... we have to
be above 50%.
So, there are forms. What is this?
If we're above 50% and  That's
the outline of Title I, meaning
that 50% of students are
identified as
economically disadvantaged. So, two years ago, it
depended on
the city, so it depended on
many students because they had
transfers, but they were in a
place where, based on the census,
50% of families were
economically disadvantaged. So, the
money can go to the
students. Now, based on
student need and the
student population, 30%
of the population identified as
economically disadvantaged can
receive ISD funds. So,
coming from Oron, we're going to access the
Title I funds. One can receive that
amount in Oron at that time. So,
we're at about
38-39%. Austin ISD
sets it, the federal level sets the minimum, and
we can go above that
number. I'm sure we're going to
have the Title I dollars. It makes a lot of
sense with this
administration,
with this in terms of education. The
Title I funds go  It has to do
with block grants. So that does
n't focus on the number of students
in need. It's more about
proportions across the
entire state. There's going to be a lot of
movement in that area, anyway
. So yes, I'm trying to
grab whatever funding I can
get. It's a way we can
impact them by going from here to there
, Title I, Title II,
Title III, Title C dollars, and
also, let's keep in mind that there's going to be more
control over Title I dollars.
Um, my goal is to create, uh,
our funds, so we don't have to be
thinking about these funds that we're not
going to take into account, and
when the state gives us that money.
That's part of the way we're
trying to create the city going forward. If
we think we can have those dollars
in terms of comprehensive services right now
, we're in
charge right now, and we're doing it right now
.
Well, thank you. I
appreciate your time, and to the
commissioners, I just want to
follow up. One of the first
questions you read.
There's something we don't like. What is this
program?  Completely?
It's a way to change the system or
pull a fast one.
The rumor is that they can transfer or
move during the spring for
next year and continue with the
priority seating we have in the
schools. I want to know if that's true,
and if not, can
you come up with some
mechanism that can help
change the program to
our benefit?
I'll tell you that I'm already aware
of several ideas that are being discussed regarding
all the transfers. I have
n't necessarily heard what you're
saying about the
spring transfers, because according to
the transfer policies, one
thing is that this school year
transfers have to be through the
district.
Well,
the transfer process can become complicated
. We have to look at
opportunities to do
mass transfers to follow the agreements we
have through the committee.
The commissioners' recommendation is that
we hold a vote, but I'll
also say that any time
someone has a desire to
circumvent the plan, we have to do something
like a trick or something to try to
bypass the system.  It aligns with what
we're trying to do and the
values ​​we have. We need to
understand that as well, and I just
wanted to mention it and share with
you
the transfer processes we have in
place. We have certain steps,
especially for Adam School, and
we discussed it because this is a
school that's already included in the
program, and the expectations, and my
team's, are protected.
Every time someone comes from another
school with a full
education program or who is outside of those
programs... Well, I had another way of
doing this, but anyway, I appreciate your
comment and your question.
Thank you for being here today, and I
appreciate your presence. I have
two questions that aren't related
to this, but I think they're important
for the consolidation plans, and I have
a 4-year-old in PRK pre-kindergarten.
These students will continue to
follow. The dual education program affiliations
will automatically transfer
with the programs to ODOM.
And I'm not clear on what you said
earlier.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. That's like I want to
revisit these scenarios, what
the previous gentleman was pointing out,
that there are different scenarios or
different possibilities where the  People
are trying to find solutions, and
for the example you gave me, we have
a precise answer. Yes. So,
we continue the programs. Yes. The
second question would be,
I've been given all the information, but I don't have it
very clear right now. I
understand that, for example,
Valal School doesn't have certain educational support,
and there are certain gaps. That
's hypothetically,
if you move to ADAM as a community,
how will the district ensure that
we have the
educational support that we currently don't have
at this school?
We all agree that Principal
Ton Navarro is an excellent principal,
and we all support
this move, if it happens. We want to have
a good foundation in
the community for our students.
It's just something we're
considering
because this is happening throughout
the district. I learned a couple of things
when I joined this project, that we
have to align the academics with the
district's guidelines. In
some cases, there are things that depend on
the academic plan, and sometimes others depend on what
happens in the classroom.
We can, obviously,
have the academic program for the
principals of each  school, but
last year we had a very large
gap because some students
were experiencing some kind of
situation at one school, but they were going to
different schools and weren't receiving the
support they were used to
. So this year, we have
specialists joining the
program, along with the superintendent, to
have a better-defined plan for
education academics.
We have to ensure that we have all the
academic support we need,
which we haven't had much time for, and this
is part of the team we have here. I
was reviewing the
previous plan that I mentioned from Maxwell,
because the plan is written, it's already available,
and it's the clearest plan we've had
in the Austin school district
. The
principal
knows it and knows the
conditions of this school and the
transition plan, and we've been quite
precise about what we expect to
happen. So, we have to look at
these gaps and see how we're going to
address them. We've specifically discussed
the gaps in this meeting and
others, but well, it's part of the
school year.
Last year we did  And
we've revisited these topics, but if
you have any specific questions,
you can send us your comments on a
card, and if this is what I'm
hearing. It's important that we know
what the community is saying.
Thank you for being here.
I'm very grateful to the team and the
committee
for giving us this opportunity and all the
opportunities they provide to communicate with
the community. I just want to understand
a little better what the
transformation transition plan is because will
the OD school be included in this plan or
not? Well, I'm going to stop because
you left me hanging with the question, right? I
just want to understand. Do
you plan to raise
the
school's current academic record? Because we'll be
arriving at this school in a
different scenario.
Do they have an excellent academic level,
or what are you expecting? There are
two things I want to say. First, do
n't let all
the information come from the grades.
We have excellent schools that may
not have an
A or B rating, but they have
a waiting list because people
want to get into those schools, and we have
ways to accommodate them.  and protect the
schools that have
high ratings. We have
very strong schools in our communities
that can stand on their own two feet and are
highly valued, respected, and powerful,
and we are proud to
have them in the school district. What
I mean is, if a
school has a certain rating, it's
because the system has failed.
We, as the school district, have
produced the results we see. We are
desperately trying to shift
the responsibility and remove [the problem], but
cleaning this up takes time. What
we are seeing is that we are protecting
our employees, the
librarians, the people who create
the curriculum.
I know there are people who organize the
curriculum, but they are being
welcomed by the community.
But these transformation plans
require three UAs, which
means unacceptable. The
rating
is a combination of events, for
example, two FSs, which are two
failing grades.
If you have UAs, it's unacceptable. For
example, one F for failing grade is a
failing grade. If you have two, that's
grounds for
having problems next year.
school year and we have to implement the
plans we're making for the next
school year.
At the moment, it was the 2024-2025 school year
. We're trying to follow the
same timeline, and we have a
few more challenges right now.
For example, we have three FES (Faculty of Education) in these
schools, as you already know. For
that, we have to have a
different approach, a
different plan, and different ways to
avoid having the fourth
failing grade. I
just want to be honest
with you and wish you all success in
the upcoming schools that are being
transferred. In 2023, we had 30, in
2024, 29, and then we had 23. Our
systems have been going in other ways, and without
the transformation plan,
academic performance has dropped a bit,
but we're providing support,
assuming this plan moves forward and
can be implemented well. We have the
time, and we're modeling. There isn't a
transformation plan at this school
in Odom. Just so we're
clear on this. I answered the
question. Yes. I
just want to make sure we're
limiting the questions to  Five minutes
to give everyone time to
ask their questions. Good afternoon. We are
grateful for the way you have come to
represent us.
We have had several meetings here in
Venezuela to try to engage and
understand the
diverse perspectives and needs of
the families living here. There are people
who live further afield who have been told, "We do
n't have space in San
Cerrado," and there are families who have said, "
We live near San Cerrado, we walk to
school," and this is critical for
us. We don't trust the
transportation system because we have had
negative experiences. Although we all
love our principal,
Navarro, not all families will be
able to continue with the
new program. So it is very
important, as has been said, for
families to be able to choose, to have all
the information possible
about what the plan is for the program
in Josing compared to Organs, what is
currently planned, which will be like the
overflow for those who fit in the
southern community without wanting to continue with
individual education. So, what more
details can you share with us about the
model?  or educational transfers,
how is a large community through
needs
is repeating the same question that
was asked in Spanish.  It's only being
translated into English,
although we want our teachers,
our principal, to know how this transition is going to be done
.
I just want to have more clarity
for Joseln,
what choices we have to know what
educational models the schools have,
if they will have dual language or
specifically what version and if it will be to
have a stronger
dual language community, whether for uh Joseln OD
or more.
We have
many programs
in 57 of the dual language schools.
We're talking about
having 78 schools, and 56 of them have
dual language,
and when they become emerging bilingual schools,
we start offering [something].  If there are 18
emerging bilingual students,
we offer dual language throughout the
school.  We are looking for resources to
ensure we can continue doing that.
So we will continue to have this
program in schools and throughout the school,
and when we talk about
whole-school dual language,
we want you to know how important it
is and how beautiful it is, and we want to
support it.
That's not a point of contention
, is it?
And it's going to be very much alive for decades to
come.
And I want to tell you
that our bilingual students, whether it's
8 or 9% and also the board's standard
,
passed legislation
that every educator wants certified
and two years ago what will happen is that in two years
we will have certified
dual language teachers
in the classroom environment.
And if not, I have to cover it by
law, I have to make sure that we have
certified teachers in every class, in
every classroom.
We have an urgent need to address something we
are encountering.  The law is
changing and certifications
are limited.  So, we are
trying to find these educators
who will serve our students.
It's something we want to talk about, something that's
happening.
And if I don't have enough educators,
then I have to
have these teachers
and our students are
here.  The board will support
the administration.
We need to know where
emerging bilingual students are located in order to have that
program.  Our transportation service
carries 20,000 students every day, and
we want to know why families are
n't taking advantage of this.
There are opportunities to access
school, but we transport
students all day, every day,
so they can have access.  If there's anything you haven't
seen that would be useful, please
let us know.  We want to be
aware of what we can do and
we are committed to helping you.
And thinking about when there is overpopulation,
uh, I don't think Joslin is going to be
overpopulated, but we want to
provide these opportunities in
South Austin and we want the
programs to be vibrant
and also timely. We're going to
offer them in the north as well, but in
South Austin we see the schools we
have
and we want to give families access to them.
so that they have more schools open in their own area
,
but to see the balance, the
equilibrium that we have to create.
Uh, I'll see, she'll answer you.
Um,
we want to give more clarification
in the next draft, and the
dual language programs are looking for
native Spanish speakers in one language and
non-native speakers so that we all
have an agreement in these programs.  Wow, it
really is very impressive.
The students are learning to
write in two languages.   They
are not separate classes.  All
students are learning the same thing.
They are learning together.  An
emerging program
follows a similar design,
but primarily it
is for students whose
first language is English.   They may
not be surrounded by only
students who speak like that,
but many times they will be speaking the
language they speak at home.
But most of them speak
English, but they value
learning Spanish
in this case, or Mandarin too, for families who value it,
right?
Uh, in spring, sorry, in elementary school
we have these programs and they are
focused
on also supporting native
English speakers and they are fully investment programs
.
The design is very similar;
it's an instruction in English.   It's
very similar to immersion in
dual language learning,
but there are no
emerging bilingual students.
When we speak the dual language of the whole
school, we also want to ensure there are
enough students in the program that is being
implemented.
When
we talk about the support given, we do
n't want the
dual language offering to be withdrawn,
because that would also create other types
of pressures for us.
In certain areas,
these problems will persist in the long
term.
I want to tell you first of all not to
envy your position at this time.  I know these are
very difficult decisions
and thank you for going through this process.
Speaking for myself,
we know that the
families of S are in shock that our
school is closing.
Questions like the one I
wanted to ask have already been asked.
and the role that security plays in the
conversation.
Honestly, there are things I'm
more confused about than before I came here.
One thing I heard is
that even if there is a student in the
school, we are going to keep it safe.  And
I'm grateful, I'm grateful for this, right?
Because I want my son to be safe at
school, and I think all parents
want the same thing.   I
'm not rejecting Joseln, I'm sure
they have a good culture, they have good
teachers,
but what they did find was that
needles in the playground
and what happens in that area,
the police are called frequently.
We know that the Austin police have a
lot of work, right? Too much.  But
mainly my question is whether we have
this school where the
police station is 3 miles away,
or if it always depends on traffic and
whether they walk and so on,
and also if they don't have enough
students enrolled
in that school.  that belong to the
neighborhood.  I'm confused.  In other words, it's going to
be non-sonicated,
meaning it's going to be less safe if the
district building
doesn't meet the same standards as this
building
because that non-sonicated school isn't
put here, which is safer.
The security component could actually be
a security measure; it's a decision.
Why don't we put Joseln's program
here?
S has been proven, right?  That does
n't matter, the financing
is provided here.
What would happen to the land, the
building?
So, it wouldn't just be another
concrete extension that we can see
in our neighborhood.
Let's tell her to answer the second
question.  No,
our answer is
not like, let him have all this.  It
's not a case of leaving it here next to
Burger.
He's talking about Bigol, the
early childhood center,
but we look at the community and the
needs, but also balance what's
happening in the district.   All
we want is for the
community and the
eastern district to agree so that everything makes
sense.
But I want the community to understand that I'm not
going to work to have a
disease here, right?, in the
district, but I want the place,
the location, the vibrancy
and for everything to look good.
But we need this conversation and for
the board to receive this
information,
and that's why we have this process.
Regarding security, I
know it's difficult
because it's important for education.
There are many schools in the district; some are
safer, some are less
safe.  It's misleading, isn't it?
When you see it, it's different information in
general.
We talked
about all the things that come into play,
talking about security,
I'm aware
of the things that happen.  I understand that.   That's all I
want.
We know that we will always encounter
challenges.
What's safe inside the school, the principal
is good, but what happens outside, well,
that might not be up to us,
right?
They
understand the things around them,
but we know there are things beyond
our control.
But
I want to acknowledge and
have more clarity on
all the elements that come into play
because we chose this school.
Uh, when we expand these limits to
add more students to Joselin,
we have to pull more schools.
And I also want you to understand
that this is happening because we are
talking about the need to modify
the boundaries
and to allow for more expansion of certain
areas.
So, remember that
we are mainly basing our
conclusions on
these changes.  Right now we have,
you know there are more questions and I'm
going to encourage you to fill out a
comment card.  They can take
this code and we are trying to
incorporate
these ideas.  our next
proposal.
Uh, I like to close.  I want to say
thank you.
I appreciate how you are handling
this part of the process.
I really like the way, the strategy,
how they are working.
It's difficult with the people we're
working with to close any
school, but I appreciate their help in
making certain adjustments as well.  Thank you.